>> Dana: BREAKING NEWS OUT OF
WASHINGTON.
AN EXPLOSIVE MEETING IN
WASHINGTON AFTER THEY REPORTEDLY
WALKED OUT OF A MEETING WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE TOPIC AT HAND, SYRIA.
TRUMP CALLED PELOSI A THIRD-RATE
POLITICIAN.
EARLIER TODAY, I SAID WE WILL
GET BACK TO YOU IF ANYTHING BAG
HAPPENS.
HERE YOU ARE.
>> THERE YOU HAVE IT.
WELL DONE.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
THE WHITE HOUSE SAYS THE
PRESIDENT WAS MEASURED,
DECISIVE, AND FACTUAL.
THEY CALLED THE WALKOUT BY
NANCY PELOSI BAFFLING BUT NOT
SURPRISING.
WHILE, HER COLLEAGUES SAY THE
PRESIDENT WAS DOWNRIGHT
INSULTING.
HE WAS HAVING A MELTDOWN.
HERE'S WHAT CHUCK SCHUMER SAID
ABOUT IT NOT LONG AGO.
>> IT WAS INSULTING,
PARTICULARLY TO THE SPEAKER.
SHE KEPT HER COOL COMPLETELY.
BUT HE CALLED HER A THIRD-RATE
POLITICIAN.
HE SAID THAT THERE ARE
COMMUNISTS INVOLVED AND YOU GUYS
MIGHT LIKE THAT.
I MEAN, THIS WAS NOT A DIALOGUE.
IT WAS SORT OF A NASTY DIATRIBE
NOT FOCUSED ON THE FACTS.
SPEAK ABOUT THE DEMOCRAT'S SIDE
OF THINGS.
ON THE G.O.P. SIDE, THEY SAID
THAT THE SPEAKER DID NOT HAVE AN
INTENTION OF LISTENING OR
CONTRIBUTING TO THIS ISSUE.
SHE JUST WANTED TO HAVE HER WAY.
HERE'S MR. McCARTHY.
>> YOU SEE A PATTERN OF BEHAVIOR
WITH SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI.
SHE STORMS OUT OF ANOTHER
MEETING, TRYING TO MAKE IT
UNPRODUCTIVE.
THE OTHER DEMOCRATS, THEY
ACTUALLY HAD A VERY PRODUCTIVE
MEETING.
>> Kevin: AND YOU PROBABLY
KNOW THIS, DANY, DANA, THAT HAS
BEN'S DOLL
THAT HAS BEEN CANCELED.
>> Greg: IT'S BETTER THAN
BEING A FIRST RATE POLITICIAN.
A FIRST RATE POLITICIAN, YOU ARE
JUST A PHONY.
BUT TRUMP IS A 12TH RATE
POLITICIAN.
THAT DOESN'T EVEN REGISTER, SO
IT'S ACTUALLY A COMPLIMENT.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY THE WORST
THING THAT HAS EVER HAPPENED
SINCE YESTERDAY WHEN THE WORST
THING THAT EVER HAPPENED
HAPPENED AND THEN BEFORE THAT.
THE FACT IS, EVERY DAY WITH
THESE PEOPLE, IT'S THE WORST
THING.
THEIR HAIR IS ON FIRE ALL THE
TIME.
YOU CAN SEE IT FROM SPACE.
THEY ARE SMOKY HEADS ARE
FLAMING.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT IT ANYMORE.
YOU CAN DISAGREE WITH THEM ABOUT
THIS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DO.
BUT THE FACT IS, THIS IS WHO
TRUMP IS.
HE IS AMERICA'S CABDRIVER.
IF YOU ASK HIM, IF YOU GO, THIS
MIDDLE EAST BUSINESS.
IT'S A BUNCH OF.
WHAT ARE WE DOING THERE?
NO ONE GETS ANYTHING DONE.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
THAT'S OUR PRESIDENT.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH A QUESTION
MARK >> Juan: THAT SCARY.
>> Greg: OF NO, HE'S A HUMAN
BEING.
>> Juan: NO, IT'S NOT.
YOU WANT SOMEONE AS YOUR LEADER.
IN FACT, HE IS CREATING MORE
RISK.
NORMALLY, ON THE SHOW, WE HAVE A
DEBATE ABOUT THINGS THAT ARE
REPUBLICAN-DEMOCRAT-CONSERVATIVE
-LIBERAL.
WHATEVER.
BUT, GREG, THIS IS LIKE 129
REPUBLICANS TODAY INCLUDING ALL
OF THE HOUSE REPUBLICAN
LEADERSHIP.
PUTTING US AMERICANS RIGHT HERE
AT HOME AT RISK.
ISIS PEOPLE BEING RELEASED TO
THE WORLD WITHOUT ANY CONTROL.
>> Dana: I THINK THEY HAVE HIS
BEST INTEREST IN MIND IN THE
CRITICISM.
>> Jesse: FOR ME, IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT WHEN THERE IS
BIPARTISAN CONSENSUS TO STAY IN
SYRIA.
OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTRY, THERE
OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTRY. THERE
THAT'S THE DISCONNECT.
YOU'VE GOT THE ARAB SPRING.
YOU'VE GOT.
YOU'VE GOT WARS.
YOU'VE GOT EVERYTHING GOING ON.
A MIGRATION CRISIS.
WEAPONS OF MASS DESTRUCTION.
HE IS SAYING ENOUGH.
LET'S LET EVERYONE FIGHT AND GET
THE OUT OF HERE.
>> Dana: NOW, HE'S TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT THE DIPLOMACY PIECE.
I THINK YOU COULD AGREE, LET'S
GET OUT, BUT MAYBE JUST TRYING
TO FIND A WAY TO GET OUT WITH
LESS BLOODSHED.
>> Emily: PEOPLE ARE DYING IN
SYRIA, AND TURKEY, AND
EVERYWHERE.
MY TAX DOLLARS ARE PAYING THE
SALARY FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SITTING THERE AND STORMING OUT
AT MEETINGS LIKE IT'S TOO LITTLE
KIDS OR THREE KIDS.
NO HE DID IT, NO HE DID IT, MOM.
I DON'T CARE.
I WANT THEM TO FIGURE IT OUT.
THESE
I'ESE
I'MSE
I'M SO SICK OF THE CIVIL WAR
HAPPENING AND THE INSULTS FROM
THIS BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT.
WE PAY THEM AND WE PUT OUR FAITH
IN THEM TO PAY THESE OFFICES TO
COME UP WITH A CONSENSUS.
>> Juan: BUT HOW DO YOU ARGUE
WITH A CABDRIVER?
YOU CAN'T JUST SAY, OH, LET'S
GET OUT.
>> Greg: HERE'S THE DEBATE
THAT'S GOING ON TODAY.
YOU HAVE A GROUP OF PEOPLE THAT
SEE THE POTENTIAL TO HURT TRUMP
AND SO THEY ARE BUILDING IT UP.
IT'S ANOTHER THING.
REMEMBER, LAST WEEK, IT WAS
IMPEACHMENT.
THIS WEEK, IT'S THIS.
GO FIND SOMETHING ELSE.
THERE IS ACTUALLY A LEGITIMATE
POINT THAT TRUMP IS MAKING AND
HAS BEEN MAKING FOR ALMOST 20
YEARS.
>> Juan: BUT WHAT I'M SAYING
TO YOU IS, THE REPUBLICANS HAVE
LARGELY STAYED WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN OPPOSITION TO
THE IMPEACHMENT.
BUT WE SEE SOMETHING DIFFERENT
HERE, GREG.
THIS IS FAR MORE SERIOUS.
>> Dana: CAN I MAKE AN
HISTORICAL COMPARISON?
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GO BACK TO FAR
TO ONE PRESIDENT OBAMA DECIDED
TO NOT ENFORCE THE REDLINE?
I THINK THEY WERE DEMOCRATS WHO
TOLD HIM THAT IT WAS A TERRIBLE
IDEA.
YOU HAD CLINTON AND GATES
ALL RIGHT BOOKS, AND CARRY, ALL
SAY THAT THAT WAS NOT A GOOD
DECISION.
THERE WAS A TERRIBLE DECISION.
>> Juan: BUT I THINK THE
DIFFERENCE HERE, DANA, IS THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS SAYING THAT
THOSE KURDS WHO ARE THEIR ALLIES
AND WHO DIED IN OUR FIGHTS, THEY
ARE NO ANGELS.
OH, THERE'S A LOT OF --
>> Greg: THERE IS A
COMPLICATED ISSUE WITH THE
KURDS.
THERE IS WITH EVERYBODY.
>> Jesse: WHAT HAPPENED TO THE
SOUTH VIETNAMESE?
REMEMBER WHAT HAPPENED THERE?
>> Greg: WE LEFT THAT WHOLE
COUNTRY.
>> Juan: THAT'S A TERRIBLE
EXAMPLE.
SPEAK TO MY POINT IS THAT HE
DOESN'T WANT AMERICANS TO DIE.
WITH OTHER PEOPLE WANT TO FIGHT
AND KILL EACH OTHER, WHICH
THEY'VE BEEN DOING --
>> Dana: NOW, HE SAYING THAT
HE DOESN'T WANT THEM TO.
HE'S JUST SENT A LETTER SAYING,
"DON'T BE A FOOL."
I THINK THAT PRESIDENT COULD
HAVE HAD ALL THE RESULTS THAT
HE'S LOOKING FOR NOW.
>> Greg: DANA'S POINT IS WELL
TAKEN.
EVERYTHING COULD HAVE BEEN DONE
BETTER TRUMP IS KNOWN FOR GOING
OUT, HE SHOOTS FIRST AND THEN
AIMS LATER, WHATEVER YOU WANT TO
USE, THE METAPHOR.
THE POINT IS, HIS SIMPLE LOGIC,
AND I DON'T MEAN SIMPLE AS
STUPID.
I MEAN THAT IT'S PLAIN AS DAY.
OUR MEN AREN'T GOING TO GET
KILLED.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HE SAYS.
YOU CAN GET MAD AT HIM AND
DISAGREE WITH HIM, BUT HE WILL
ACCEPT THE DEATHS OF THE KURDS
BEFORE HE ACCEPTS THE DEATHS OF
AMERICAN TROOPS.
>> Dana: THE QUESTION IS, IF
YOU HAVE THE POWER TO PREVENT
IT, AND ALSO, I DO THINK THAT
WHEN THESE REPUBLICANS ARE
SAYING, WE ARE AFRAID OF WHAT
COULD HAPPEN, BECAUSE IF
SOMETHING HAPPENS IN A YEAR OR